those who worship don't know those who
know don't worship
to seek is to suffer to seek nothing is
bliss
at every moment where language can't go
that's your mind
according to the sutras evil Deeds
result in hardships Good Deeds result in
blessings
foreign
[Music]
few actually walk it
not engaging in ignorance is wisdom
[Music]
take up one idea make that one idea your
life think of it dream of it live on
that idea this is the way to success
a Buddha is someone who finds freedom
and good fortune and bad
people of this world are deluded they're
always longing for something always in a
word seeking
but God will show Mercy though you show
none
and where is the Merit of your boasted
virtue
a Buddha is an idol person he doesn't
run around after fortune and fame
[Music]
regardless of what we do our Karma has
no hold on us
[Music]
the ignorant mind with its infinite
afflictions passions and evils is rooted
in these three poisons greed anger and
delusion
freeing oneself from words is liberation
[Music]
the way is basically perfect it doesn't
require perfecting
you haven't partied until you've partied
at dawn in complete silence with
Buddhist monks
our own brain our own heart is our
Temple the philosophy is kindness
my imagination is a monastery and I am
its Monk
Purity in life unknowingly you seek
death
the only truly secure place is your
grave
[Music]
it's full and kind one monk is more
valuable than violent and rude ten
thousand men
ardently due today what must be done
everything that happens to us is the
result of what we ourselves have thought
said and done
[Music]
true and Lasting inner peace can never
be found in external things
those who cling to perceptions and Views
wander the world offending people
[Music]
happiness will never come to those who
fail to appreciate what they already
have
[Music]
to stop suffering stop greed greed is a
source of suffering
pain is certain suffering optional
[Music]
forgive and be free forget that you have
forgiven and be Freer
[Music]
foreign
s cannot be long hidden the Sun the moon
and the truth
[Music]
do not be the judge of people do not
make assumptions about others
I describe myself as a simple Buddhist
monk no more no less
[Laughter]
be like a tree the tree gives shade even
to him who cuts off his spouse
the gift of knowledge is the highest
gift in the world
the world is our actions follow the call
of fate and there will be no doubt
you recognize a beginner by his
arrogance a diligent student by the
strength of his blow and a master by his
ease of movement
[Music]
the fist beats in the space where the
cow can lie down
[Music]
a fist has a shape a punch has no shape
strong on the outside calm on the inside
there are methods for Yin there are
methods for yang
meet the hard with a soft transformation
meet the soft with a heart attack
all martial arts under the sky come from
Shaolin
don't think too much thinking takes
energy and makes you old
Mastery becomes natural after a thousand
days
the fist strikes a thousand times and
the methods of action with the body are
natural
the fist does not have the same
abilities as the Palm but the Palm is
incomparable in its skill with the blow
of the fingers
a real master beats with his palm a
student with his fist
no one comes back from travel the way he
was before
if you stumble and fall it does not mean
that you are going the wrong way
on the hand that gives roses their
fragrance will always remain
from time to time please someone even
yourself
a big river flows quietly a smart person
does not raise his voice
he who does not know how to rest cannot
work well either
[Music]
parents give you life bring up the will
yourself
if you make a mistake it is better to
laugh right away
the best time to plant a tree was 20
years ago the next best time is today
it is better to demand from yourself
than to ask from others
make happy those who are near and those
who are far away will come to you
it's better to be able to listen than to
speak
[Music]
better one day to be a man than a
thousand days to be a shadow
[Music]
if you didn't learn anything in a day
you spent a day in vain
[Music]
if there is a determination to break
through a stone it will crack itself
[Music]
a wise man has long ears and a short
tongue
don't be afraid to slow down be afraid
to stop
treat your thoughts like guests and your
desires like children
those who claim it is impossible should
not distract those who do
[Music]
live in peace come spring and the
flowers bloom themselves
if a flowering Branch remains in my soul
a singing bird will sit on it
[Music]
New Year and the mouse rejoices
don't speak unless it improves the
silence
cannot bear small problems we'll never
accomplish anything great
it is better to teach a son than to
leave him a box of gold
[Music]
teachers open the door you enter
yourself
[Music]
100 moves five times
is of no use whatsoever
but practice one move every day and it
will be your lifetime protector
[Music]
if you manage to forget your eye then
you can feel yourself an integral part
of the cosmos
[Music]
the secret to martial arts is not style
but training
the possession of anything begins in the
mind
[Music]
to know oneself is to study oneself in
action with another person
[Music]
the key to immortality is first living a
life worth remembering
showing off is the Fool's idea of Glory
[Music]
take no thought of who is right or wrong
or who is better
be not for or against
only Through The Eyes of others can you
see your shortcomings
the trick of life is to die young but as
late as possible
the best fight is the one that never
happened
he got up late he lost a day he did not
study in his youth he lost his life
a journey of a Thousand Miles begins
with one step
failure adds intelligence
to make a mistake is a misdemeanor
to not admit a mistake is a crime
the sign of intelligence is that you are
constantly wondering
foreign
think of yourself before judging others
[Music]
doubt a person do not do business with
him if you do do not doubt
[Music]